From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
I lie, probably, every weekend to my mom.
我大概每个周末都会对妈妈撒谎。
So, about what kinds of things?
那么，是关于哪方面的事情呢？
Mostly drinking and what time I get home. Where I am. Who I'm with.
主要是喝酒、回家的时间，我在哪里，以及我和谁在一起。
This girl is a high school senior. And let's just identify her as living somewhere in North America. And, probably, the biggest lie she perpetrated against her mom was an ongoing deception that lasted two years, starting when she was 14, a freshman.
这个女孩是一名高中生。我们暂且假设她住在北美某处。她对妈妈撒过最大的谎，可能是一个持续了两年的长期欺骗，从她14岁读高一的时候就开始了。
She would stay out till midnight in the park with her friends, drinking, most Friday and Saturday nights, which her mom definitely would not allow. So she told her mom that they were at a Chinese restaurant every weekend for two years. She'd come home drunk and convince her mom she was sober.
在两年的时间里，每个周五和周六晚上，她都会和朋友在公园里待到午夜喝酒，这绝对是她妈妈不允许的。所以她骗妈妈说每个周末都在一家中餐馆。她喝得醉醺醺地回到家，还要假装清醒骗过妈妈。
What I'm doing, she never normally, really finds out. Like, I think she has no idea that I hung out in a park for two years of my life.
我做的事，她从来没真正发现过。我觉得她根本不知道我人生中有两年是在公园里度过的。
And what would happen if she found out?
如果她发现了会怎么样？
I think she'd just be really upset, because she really thinks she knows exactly what's going on in my life, and she really has no idea. I think that would just hurt her.
我觉得她会非常难过，因为她真的以为自己很了解我的生活，可她根本一点都不知道。我觉得那会伤害到她。
Oh, she thinks you guys are really close.
噢，她以为你们关系非常好。
Yeah, she thinks we are really close. And, yeah, she thinks she knows everything I do, and she doesn't.
是的，她以为我们关系很亲密。而且，是的，她以为她知道我做的一切，但其实她不知道。
But now, they're both at a turning point. Graduation is next week, which makes this girl just old enough that she's starting to wonder if, someday, she should let her mom know the truth about all of it. In the past when she thought about telling her mom the truth, it was actually more  of a revenge kind of thing.
但现在，她们俩都到了一个转折点。下周就要毕业了，这让女孩觉得自己长大了，开始考虑是否有一天应该告诉妈妈这一切真相。过去当她想告诉妈妈真相时，其实更多是出于报复心理。
There have been points where, I really just want my mom to feel kind of stupid and let down. Has been points when, I've been really mad at her, we haven't been getting along, that's been like, I want to make you feel like you really don't know what you're talking about. Because every time she's always like, you know I'll always catch you. You know I always know what you're doing.
曾有几次，我真的只想让妈妈感到难堪和失望。当我真的很生她的气，我们相处不融洽时，我就想：我要让你觉得你根本不知道自己在说什么。因为她总是说：“你知道我总会抓到你的。你知道我总是知道你在干什么。”
And there's been points where I just want to be like, listen mom, you really don't know what's going on. This is what's happened for the past four years of my life. You really haven't known much. It would just be like a really big power trip for me.
有时候我真想说：“听着，妈，你根本不知道发生了什么。这是我过去四年生活里发生的事。你根本什么都不知道。”那对我来说会是一种巨大的权力快感。
And now with school ending and college so soon, already her mom is loosening up the reins and not checking up on her so much. She could see that maybe it would be best for everybody, her and her mom, if the truth never came out. And if it did come out, she'd want it to be for a good reason.
现在学校快结束了，马上就要上大学，她妈妈已经放松了管制，不再那么频繁地查岗。她发现，如果真相永远不被揭露，对大家——她和她妈妈——来说或许是最好的。如果真的要说出来，她希望是有正当理由的。
I mean, I might not never tell her, might not ever tell her about the park. I'll see. I've actually thought about it. I've had serious thoughts about telling her the truth, once I'm in college. I really do want to become close to my mom again.
我是说，我也可能永远不会告诉她，可能永远不会告诉她公园的事。走着瞧吧。其实我考虑过。我认真想过等我上大学后告诉她真相。我真的很想和妈妈重新亲近起来。
We had a really big falling out, especially, when she started going out with her boyfriend. And we have gotten a lot closer since we started talking again, and like we told each other how we feel and stuff. And it's just-- I have a lot of older friends who have had some troubles with their parents in the past and like, once they were in college, got really close to them again. And I really want that.
我们曾有过很大的分歧，特别是在她开始和男朋友约会的时候。自从我们重新开始交流后，关系亲近了很多，我们互相诉说了自己的感受。而且……我有很多年龄大点的朋友，过去也和父母有过矛盾，等他们上大学后，又和父母变得很亲密了。我真的很想要那样。
Like, I want to be closer with my mom. I want to be able to tell her everything and tell her the truth. And so I think that is the main reason that I would tell her at this point. I don't really need her to be feeling stupid anymore like, now it'd just be to get close.
比如，我想和妈妈更亲近。我想能把所有事情都告诉她，告诉她真相。所以我认为这是我现在告诉她的主要原因。我不再需要让她感到难堪了，现在这么做只是为了拉近关系。
I think one of the least accurate truisms, or if it's a folk wisdom, is the idea, the truth will come out. Of course, it doesn't come out. So many lies are so small, they're not even worth exposing. And then any lie that matters, has somebody invested in keeping it a lie. In a way it's remarkably rare for the truth to come out at all. It takes ingenuity, and effort, and cunning, and a decision.
我认为最不准确的至理名言之一，或者说民间智慧，就是“真相总会大白”这种说法。当然，真相并不会大白。太多的谎言微不足道，根本不值得揭穿。而任何重要的谎言，都有人致力于维护它。某种程度上，真相大白是非常罕见的。这需要独创性、努力、狡黠，以及一个决定。
Today we have three stories of lies, finally exposed, each under very dramatic circumstances. Act one, "Lieland" in which we bring you a cheerfully and surprisingly unrepentant story about lying.
今天我们有三个关于谎言最终被揭露的故事，每个故事都发生在非常戏剧性的情况下。第一幕，“谎言之地”，我们将为你带来一个关于撒谎的、欢快且出人意料地毫无悔意的故事。
Act two, "The Spy Who Bugged Me," journalist Lawrence Wright tries to uncover some basic truths about whether his phone is being tapped and by whom. And when he finds the whom behind it, they are also surprisingly unrepentant.
第二幕，“窃听我的间谍”，记者劳伦斯·赖特试图揭开一些基本真相，弄清楚他的电话是否被窃听，以及被谁窃听。而当他找到背后的指使者时，他们也出人意料地毫无悔意。
Act three, "Rosa In The Study With the ATM Card," A woman tries to get to the bottom of a domestic mystery in her father's house. And the suspect, one of the butlers, kind of. Stay with us.
第三幕，“书房里的罗莎与自动取款机卡”，一位女士试图弄清她父亲家里的一个家庭谜团。而嫌疑人，某种意义上，是管家之一。请留步。
Act one, "Lieland," we start with this story about lying from Etgar Keret, who has been on our show before. He is an Israeli writer. This story was read for us by actor Dermot Mulroney.
第一幕，“谎言之地”，我们从埃特加·凯雷特关于撒谎的故事开始，他曾来过我们的节目。他是一位以色列作家。这个故事由演员德蒙特·莫罗尼为我们朗读。
Robbie was seven when he told his first lie. His mother had given him a wrinkled, old, 10 lira bill and asked him to go buy a pack of king-sized Kents at the grocery store. Robbie bought an ice cream cone instead. He took the change and hid the coins under a white rock in the backyard of their apartment building.
罗比七岁时说了第一个谎。他妈妈给了他一张皱巴巴的旧10里拉钞票，让他去杂货店买一包特大号肯特香烟。罗比却买了支冰淇淋。他把剩下的零钱藏在公寓楼后院的一块白石头下面。
And when mother asked him what had happened, he told her that a giant red-headed kid, with a front-tooth missing, tackled him in the street, slapped him, and took the money. Mother believed him. And Robbie hadn't stopped lying since.
当妈妈问他发生了什么事时，他告诉她，街上跑来一个长着红头发、门牙缺了一颗的巨人小孩，把他扑倒，打了他一巴掌，抢走了钱。妈妈相信了他。从那以后，罗比就没停止过撒谎。
When he was in high school, he spent the better part of an entire week vegging out on the beach in Eilat, after selling the student counselor a story about his aunt from Beersheba, who discovered she had cancer. When he was in the army, this imaginary aunt went blind and saved his ass big-time for going AWOL-- no detention, not even confined to barracks, nothing.
他上高中时，卖给学生辅导员一个关于他来自贝尔谢巴的阿姨发现自己患了癌症的故事，然后用那一周的大部分时间在埃拉特的沙滩上游手好闲。他在军队时，这位虚构的阿姨失明了，让他因为擅离职守而彻底脱身——没有禁闭，甚至没有关禁闭，什么惩罚都没有。
Once, he justified being two hours late to work with a lie about a German shepherd he'd found lying beside the road. The dog had been run over, and Robbie had taken it to the vet. In this lie, the dog remained paralyzed in two of its legs. Those legs did the trick.
有一次，他编了一个关于他在路边发现一只德国牧羊犬的谎言，为自己上班迟到两小时开脱。那条狗被车撞了，罗比把它送到了兽医那里。在这个谎言中，那条狗的两条腿瘫痪了。那些腿（伤势）起了作用。
There were a lot of lies along the way in Robbie's life: lies without arms, and lies that were ill, lies that do harm, and lies that could kill, lies with legs, lies on wheels, lies in tuxedos, lies that steal, lies he made up in a flash and just as soon forgot about.
罗比的人生中一路上有许多谎言：没腿的谎言，生病的谎言，造成伤害的谎言，能杀人的谎言，有腿的谎言，车轮上的谎言，穿礼服的谎言，偷窃的谎言，他瞬间编造出来又转眼就忘掉的谎言。
It all started with a dream, a short, fuzzy dream about his dead mother. In this dream, the two of them are sitting on a straw mat in the middle of a clear, white surface, devoid of all detail, that seemed to have no beginning and no end. Next to them on this infinite, white surface was a gumball machine with a bubble top, the old fashioned kind where you put a coin in the slot, turn the handle and out comes a gumball.
这一切始于一个梦，一个关于他已故母亲的短暂而模糊的梦。在梦里，他们俩坐在一片干净、洁白、没有任何细节、似乎没有尽头也没有起点的表面的草垫上。在他们旁边，这片无限的白色表面上，有一台泡泡顶的自动售货机，那种老式的，往槽里投硬币，转动把手，就会掉出一个口香糖的机器。
And in his dream, Robbie's mother told him that the afterworld was driving her up the wall. Because the people there were OK, but there were no cigarettes-- not just no cigarettes, no coffee or talk shows, nothing.
在梦里，罗比的母亲告诉他，来世的生活让她抓狂。因为那里的人都挺好，但没有香烟——不只是没有香烟，还没有咖啡或脱口秀，什么都没有。
"You've got to help me Robbie," she said. "You've got to buy me a gumball. I raised you. All these years, I gave you everything and asked for nothing, but now it's time to give something back to your mom. Get me a gum ball, a red one if you can, but blue is OK, too."
“你得帮我，罗比，”她说。“你得给我买个口香糖。我把你养大。这些年来，我为你付出了一切，却什么也没要，但现在是时候回报你妈妈了。给我买个口香糖，如果是红色的最好，蓝色的也行。”
And in his dream, Robbie rummaged through his pockets, over and over, trying to find some change. Nothing.
在梦里，罗比反复摸索口袋，想找些零钱。什么都没有。
"I haven't got any, Mom," he said, the tears welling in his eyes. "I haven't got any change. I've gone through all my pockets."
“我没有零钱，妈，”他说，眼里涌出了泪水。“我没有零钱。我把所有口袋都翻遍了。”
Considering that he never cried when he was awake, it was strange to be crying in his dream.
考虑到他清醒时从不哭泣，在梦里哭泣显得很奇怪。
"Did you look under the rock?" his mother asked, and clasped his hands in her own. "Maybe the coins are still there."
“你找过那块石头下面了吗？”母亲问，并握住他的双手。“也许硬币还在那里。”
Then he woke up. It was 5:00 AM on a Saturday, still dark out. Robbie found himself getting into the car and driving to the place where he had grown up. On a Saturday morning with no traffic on the road, it took less than 20 minutes to get there. On the ground floor of the building, where Plisken's grocery store had been, there was a dollar store. And next to it, instead of the shoe-repair guy, there was a cell phone outlet offering upgrades like there was no tomorrow.
然后他醒了。那是周六凌晨5点，外面还很黑。罗比发现自己钻进车里，开车前往他长大的地方。周六早晨路上没有交通，不到20分钟就到了。在楼房的一楼，曾经是普利斯肯杂货店的地方，现在是一家一美元商店。而在它旁边，代替修鞋匠的，是一家不断提供手机升级服务的门店，仿佛明天不会到来一样。
But the building itself hadn't changed. More than 20 years had gone by since they moved out, and it hadn't even been painted. The yard was still the same too, a few flowers, a spigot, a rusty water-meter, and weeds. And in the corner, next to the clotheslines, was the white rock, waiting.
但楼本身没变。距离他们搬走已经过去了20多年，连漆都没重新刷过。院子也还是老样子，几朵花，一个水龙头，一个生锈的水表，还有杂草。在角落里，晾衣绳旁边，那块白石头还在那里等着。
There he stood in the backyard of the building where he'd grown up, wearing his parka, holding a big, plastic flashlight, and feeling strange, like some kind of thief-- no, not a thief, a nutjob. 5:15 AM on a Saturday, if a neighbor were to show up, what would tell him? My dead mother appeared in my dream and asked me to buy her a gumball, so I came here to look for change?
他站在长大的楼房后院，穿着派克大衣，手里拿着个大塑料手电筒，感觉很奇怪，像个小偷——不，不是小偷，是个疯子。周六早上5点15分，如果有邻居出现，他该怎么说？我死去的母亲出现在我的梦里，让我给她买口香糖，所以我来这里找零钱？
It seemed strange that the rock would still be there after all those years. Then again, if you thought about it, it wasn't really as strange as all that. It's not as if rocks just get up and walk away. Half-afraid, he picked it up gingerly, as if there might be a scorpion hiding underneath. But there was no scorpion, and no snake, either, and no coins, just a hole the width of his arm, and a light shining out of it.
奇怪的是那块石头过了这么多年还在那儿。话说回来，如果你仔细想想，其实也没那么奇怪。石头又不会自己长腿跑掉。他带着一半恐惧，小心翼翼地把它捡起来，仿佛下面藏着蝎子。但下面既没有蝎子，也没有蛇，更没有硬币，只有一个胳膊粗的洞，还有一道光从里面射出来。
Robbie tried to peek into the hole, but the light was dazzling. He hesitated a second, then reached in. Lying on the ground, he extended his entire arm, all the way to shoulder, trying to touch something at the bottom. But there was no bottom. And the only thing he could reach was made of cold metal and felt like a handle, the handle of a gumball machine.
罗比试图往洞里窥探，但光线太刺眼了。他犹豫了一秒，然后伸手进去。他趴在地上，伸长了整条手臂，一直到肩膀，试图摸到底部的什么东西。但根本没有底部。他唯一能摸到的东西是冷冰冰的金属做的，感觉像个手柄，一个口香糖机的把手。
Robbie turned it as hard as he could and felt the handle respond to his touch. This was exactly the moment where the gumball should have rolled out. This was exactly when it should have come all the way out of the innards of the machine, right into the hand of the little boy who was waiting impatiently for it to emerge. This was exactly the point when all that was supposed to happen. But it didn't. And as soon as Robbie finished turning the handle of the machine, he showed up here.
罗比用力转动它，感觉到把手有了回应。这正是口香糖应该滚出来的那一刻。这正是它应该从机器的肠子里彻底出来，掉进那个焦急等待的小男孩手中的那一刻。这正是这一切应该发生的时候。但它没有。罗比转动完机器把手，他就出现在了这里。
Here was a different place but a familiar one too. It was the place from his mother's dream: stark white, no walls, no floor, no ceiling, no sunshine, just whiteness and a gumball machine-- a gumball machine, and a sweaty, ugly, red-headed boy. And before Robbie had a chance to smile at the boy or say anything at all, the red-head gave him a kick in the shins as hard as he could. And Robbie dropped to the ground, writhing.
这里是一个陌生但又熟悉的地方。这是他母亲梦里的那个地方：一片纯白，没有墙壁，没有地板，没有天花板，没有阳光，只有白色和一台口香糖机——一台口香糖机，还有一个满头大汗、相貌丑陋的红头发男孩。还没等罗比对那个男孩微笑或说任何话，那个红发小子就狠狠地朝他的胫骨踢了一脚。罗比痛苦地倒在地上挣扎。
Now, with Robbie down on his knees, he and the kid were the same height. The kid looked Robbie in the eye. And even though Robbie knew they'd never me, there was something familiar about him. "Who are you?" he asked the kid, who was standing up close, glaring at him.
现在罗比跪在地上，他和那个孩子一样高了。孩子看着罗比的眼睛。尽管罗比知道他们从未见过面，但他觉得这孩子有种熟悉感。“你是谁？”他问那个站得很近、正怒视着他的孩子。
"Me?" the boy answered, showing a mean smile with a front-tooth missing. "I'm your first lie."
“我？”那个男孩回答，露出了一个缺了一颗门牙的邪恶微笑。“我是你的第一个谎言。”
Robbie struggled to his feet. His leg, where the kid had kicked him, hurt like hell. The kid himself was long gone. Robbie studied the gumball machine. In between the round gumballs, there were those translucent, plastic balls with trinkets inside. He rummaged through his pocket for some change, but then remembered that the kid had grabbed his wallet before he split.
罗比挣扎着站起来。他被那孩子踢中的腿痛得要命。孩子早就没影了。罗比研究着那台口香糖机。在圆圆的口香糖之间，还有那些里面装着小饰品的半透明塑料球。他在口袋里翻找零钱，但随即想起在那个孩子溜走之前把他的钱包抢走了。
Robbie limped off in no particular direction. Since there was nothing to go by on the white surface except the gumball machine, the only thing left for him to do is to try to move away from it. Every few steps, he turned around to make sure the machine really was becoming smaller.
罗比一瘸一拐地朝一个没明确方向的地方走去。因为在白色的表面上除了口香糖机外别无他物，他唯一能做的就是尽量远离它。每走几步，他就回头看看，确认那台机器确实在变小。
At one point, he turned, and he discovered a German shepherd, with a leash dragging behind it, next to a skinny, old man with a glass eye and no hands. The dog he recognized at once, by the way it half crawled forward, its two forelegs struggling to pull its paralyzed pelvis.
走到某处时，他转过身，发现一只拖着皮带的德国牧羊犬，旁边是一个瘦弱、独眼且没有双手的枯瘦老人。他立刻认出了那只狗，因为它是一半拖着身体向前爬，两条前腿费力地拽着瘫痪的骨盆。
It was the run-over dog from one of the lies he'd told at work. The dog panting with effort and excitement, wagged its tail. He licked Robbie's hand and looked at him intently, with glistening eyes. The man held out the hook attached to the stump of his right arm, for what passed as a handshake. Robbie couldn't place him.
那是他工作中撒谎时提到的那只被撞的狗。那只狗喘着粗气，显得既费力又兴奋，摇着尾巴。它舔了舔罗比的手，用闪烁的眼睛注视着他。那个老人伸出连接在他右臂残端上的钩子，当作握手。罗比想不起他来。
"I'm Robbie," he said.
“我是罗比，”他说。
"I am Igor," the old man introduced himself and gave Robbie a pat with one of his hooks.
“我是伊戈尔，”老头自我介绍道，用其中一个钩子拍了拍罗比。
"Do we know each other?" Robbie asked, after a few seconds' awkward silence.
“我们认识吗？”在几秒钟尴尬的沉默后，罗比问。
"No," Igor said, lifting the leash with one of his hooks. "I am only here because of him. He sniffed you from miles away and got worked up. He wanted us to come."
“不，”伊戈尔用钩子提起皮带说。“我在这里只是因为他。他在几英里外就闻到了你的味道，变得很兴奋。他想让我们过来。”
"So, there's no connection between us?" Robbie asked. He felt a sense of relief as he said this.
“所以，我们之间没有任何联系？”罗比问。说这话时他感到一阵解脱。
"Between us? No, no connection. I'm somebody else's lie."
“我们之间？不，没有联系。我是别人的谎言。”
Robbie almost asked whose lie he was, but he didn't know whether the question was considered polite around here. For that matter, he'd have liked to ask what this place was exactly. And whether there were a lot more people there, or lies, or whatever they call themselves. But he thought that this also might be a sensitive topic, and that he shouldn't bring it up just yet.
罗比差点问他是谁的谎言，但他不知道这个问题在这里是否被视为礼貌。再说，他本来也想问这个地方究竟是什么。这里是否还有更多人，或者谎言，或者不管他们管自己叫什么。但他觉得这可能也是个敏感话题，现在还不宜提起。
For the moment, he patted Igor's handicapped dog. He was a nice dog and seemed happy to have met Robbie, who felt bad that he couldn't have gone and made up a lie with a little less pain and suffering in it.
目前，他拍了拍伊戈尔那只残疾的狗。它是一只好狗，见到罗比似乎很高兴，这让罗比感到难过，因为他没能编造出一个少一点痛苦和苦难的谎言。
"The gumball machine," he asked Igor, when a few minutes had passed. "What coins does it take?"
“那台口香糖机，”几分钟过去后，他问伊戈尔。“它收什么硬币？”
"Liras," the old man said. "If you don't have any--"
“里拉，”老人说。“如果你没有——”
"There was a kid here, just now," Robbie said, "he took my wallet. But even if he hadn't, there wouldn't be any liras in it."
“刚才有个孩子在这里，”罗比说，“他拿走了我的钱包。但就算他没拿，里面也没有里拉。”
"A kid with a tooth missing?" Igor asked. "That little scum steals from everyone. He even eats the dog's kennel ration. Where I come from in Russia, they take a kid like that and they'd stick him out in the snow. And they wouldn't let him back in the house until his whole body turned blue." With one of his hooks, Igor pointed to his back pocket. "In there, I got some liras. Help yourself, it's on "
“一个缺了一颗门牙的孩子？”伊戈尔问。“那个小渣滓偷所有人的东西。他甚至连狗的窝头都吃。在我老家俄国，像那样的孩子会被扔在雪地里。直到全身冻得发青才被允许进屋。”伊戈尔用其中一个钩子指了指他的后口袋。“那里有些里拉。自便吧，算我的。”
Robbie hesitated, but he took the lira out of Igor's pocket. And after thanking him, Robbie offered to give him his Swatch in return.
罗比犹豫了一下，但还是从伊戈尔的口袋里拿出了里拉。道谢后，罗比提出把他的斯沃琪手表作为回报。
"Thanks," Igor nodded. "But the last thing I need is a watch, especially a plastic one. I'm in no hurry to get anywhere anyway." When he saw Robbie looking around for something else to give him, Igor stopped him and said, "I owed you. If you hadn't made up that lie about the dog, I'd be here completely on my own. We're even."
“谢谢，”伊戈尔点点头。“但我最不需要的就是手表，特别是塑料的那种。反正我不急着去哪儿。”当他看到罗比环顾四周想找点别的东西给他时，伊戈尔拦住他说：“我欠你的。如果你没编那个关于狗的谎，我会完全孤身一人在这里。我们扯平了。”
Robbie hobbled back in the direction of the gumball machine. He was still smarting from the red-head's kick, but much less now. He dropped the lira into the slot, took a deep breath, closed his eyes, and twisted the handle quickly. When he made one full turn, he found himself stretched on the ground in the yard of their old building.
罗比一瘸一拐地往回走，朝口香糖机的方向。他被红发小子的踢击弄得还在隐隐作痛，但比刚才轻多了。他把里拉投进投币口，深吸一口气，闭上眼睛，迅速转动把手。当他转满一圈时，发现自己趴在他们老房子的院子里。
The dawn light was painting the sky dark shades of blue. Robbie pulled his arm out of the hole in the ground. When he opened his fist, there was a red gumball inside. Before he left, he replaced the rock where it had been. He didn't ask himself what had happened there in the hole. He just got in the car, backed up, and drove away.
晨光把天空染成了深蓝色。罗比把胳膊从地上的洞里抽出来。当他张开拳头时，里面是一颗红色的口香糖。离开之前，他把石头放回了原处。他没有问自己在那个洞里到底发生了什么。他只是钻进车里，倒车，离开了。
The red gumball, he put under his pillow for his mother, in case she came back in his dream. But she never did. And he never went back to their old yard. He thought about it all the time at first, about that place, about the dog, about Igor, about other lies he'd told and how lucky he was not to have met them too.
那颗红色的口香糖，他放在枕头下给母亲留着，万一她又回到梦里。但她再也没出现过。他也没再回过那个老院子。起初他一直想着那件事，想着那个地方，那条狗，伊戈尔，还有他撒过的其他谎言，以及他没遇到那些谎言本身是多么幸运。
He kept lying at first. But the lies he told were sort-of positive, the kind of lie where no one beats anyone up, and no one's crippled or dies of cancer. He couldn't make it, because he had to water the plants in some aunt's apartment while she was visiting her successful son abroad. He was late, because a cat just had kittens practically on his stoop, and he had to take care of the litter, stuff like that.
起初他还在撒谎。但他说的是那种积极的谎言，没人会挨打，没人致残或死于癌症。他撒不了谎，因为他得在某位阿姨出国探望成功儿子时给她的盆栽浇水。他迟到了，因为一只猫几乎就在他家台阶上生了小猫，他得照顾那一窝小家伙，诸如此类。
The trouble with all these positive lies was how much more complicated they were to think up, at least if you wanted them to sound plausible. In general, if you tell people something bad, they buy right into it, because it strikes them as normal. But when you make-up good things, they get suspicious.
所有这些正面谎言的问题在于，它们想起来要复杂得多，至少如果你想让它们听起来可信的话。通常，如果你告诉人们坏事，他们会全盘接受，因为这在他们看来很正常。但当你编造好事时，他们就会怀疑。
And so, very gradually, Robbie found himself tapering off with the lies. And to make sure he did less lying, he did less talking too. And to do that, he met less with people, which was supposed to leave him more time to think about life, and about the lies, and about the hole in the corner of the yard next to clotheslines. But he didn't.
于是，罗比非常缓慢地减少了撒谎。为了确保撒谎变少，他也减少了说话。为了做到这一点，他减少了和人的接触，这本应给他更多时间来思考人生、那些谎言以及晾衣绳旁边院子角落里的那个洞。但他并没有思考。
At least, not until the morning when he overheard Natasha, from accounting, talking in the hallway with the boss. Her uncle Igor had had a heart attack, and she needed some time off. Poor guy, a widower-- lost both hands in an accident a few years ago, and now his heart. He was so alone, so helpless.
至少，直到那天早上，他在走廊里无意中听到会计部的娜塔莎和老板谈话。她的叔叔伊戈尔心脏病发作了，她需要请假。可怜的家伙，鳏夫——几年前事故中失去了双手，现在又轮到心脏。他那么孤独，那么无助。
The head of accounting granted her time-off right away, no questions asked. She went to her office, took her bag, and left the building. Robbie followed her to her car, then approached her.
会计部主管立刻批准了她的假期，没问任何问题。她走进办公室，拿上包，离开了公司。罗比跟着她来到车边，然后接近她。
"You work in requisitions, don't you?" she asked, turning to face him. "Securities assistant?"
“你是做申请工作的吧？”她转身面对他问。“证券助理？”
"Yeah, my name's Robbie."
“是的，我叫罗比。”
"Cool, Robbie," Natasha said, with a nervous Russian smile. "So, what's up Robbie, need something?"
“酷，罗比，”娜塔莎带着不安的俄式微笑说。“怎么了罗比，需要什么吗？”
"It's about the lie you told earlier to the head of accounting," Robbie stammered. "I know him."
“是关于你刚才对会计部主管撒的谎，”罗比结结巴巴地说。“我认识他。”
"You follow me all the way to my car just to accuse me of being a liar?"
“你一路跟到我车边就是为了指责我是个骗子？”
"No," said Robbie. "I didn't mean to accuse you. Really, your being a liar is cool. I'm a liar, too. But this Igor from your lie, I met him. He's a good guy. And you, if you don't mind me saying so, you've made things pretty hard for him as it is. So, I just wanted to say--"
“不，”罗比说。“我没想指责你。真的，你是个骗子挺酷的。我也是个骗子。但你谎言里的这个伊戈尔，我见过他。他是个好人。至于你，如果不介意我直说，你已经让他本来就很难过的日子变得更难了。所以我只是想说——”
"Would you get out of my way," Natasha said. "You're blocking the door of my car."
“你能让开吗，”娜塔莎说。“你挡着我的车门了。”
"I know this sounds far-fetched, but I can prove it," Robbie said, feeling more and more uneasy. "This Igor doesn't have an eye. I mean, he has an eye, but only one. At one point, you must have made up something about how he'd lost an eye, right? See, how would I know that if I hadn't really met him?"
“我知道这听起来很离谱，但我可以证明，”罗比说，感到越来越不安。“这个伊戈尔没有眼睛。我是说，他有一只眼睛，但只有一只。在某个时间点，你一定编造过他是怎么丢了一只眼睛，对吧？你看，如果我没真的见过他，我怎么会知道呢？”
Natasha had already started to get into her car but stopped, "Well, how do you know that, about the glass eye? Are you a friend of Slava's?"
娜塔莎已经开始上车了，但停住了，“好吧，你是怎么知道那个关于假眼的事的？你是斯拉瓦的朋友吗？”
"I don't know any Slava." Robbie muttered, "Just Igor, really. If you want, I can take you to him."
“我不认识什么斯拉瓦，”罗比嘟囔道，“真的只认识伊戈尔。如果你愿意，我可以带你去见他。”
They were standing in the backyard of his building. Robbie moved the rock, lay down on the damp soil, and pushed his arm all the way into the hole. He kept going till his fingers felt the cold, metal handle. Natasha was standing over him. He held out his other arm and said, "hold on tight."
他们站在他楼房的后院里。罗比移开石头，躺在潮湿的泥土上，把手臂一直伸进洞里。他一直往下，直到手指摸到那个冷冰冰的金属把手。娜塔莎站在他上方。他伸出另一只手说：“抓紧了。”
Natasha looked at the man stretched out at her feet: thirty-something, good looking in an ironed, white shirt, now slightly more wrinkled and soiled. His one arm was stuck in the hole, his cheek was glued to the ground.
娜塔莎看着躺在她脚下的人：三十多岁，衣着整齐，白衬衫，现在稍微多了点褶皱和污渍。他的一只手臂陷在洞里，脸贴在地上。
"Hold tight," he said.
“抓紧，”他说。
And as she held out her hand to him, she couldn't help wondering how it was she always wound up with the oddballs. When he'd started with that nonsense by the car, she thought maybe it was a cute way of hitting on her. But now she realized the guy with the soft eyes and the bashful smile, really was a nutcase. His fingers were clasping hers. They stayed that way, frozen for a minute or so, him on the ground, and her standing over him slightly stooped, looking bewildered.
当她向他伸出手时，她不禁纳闷自己怎么总是和怪人凑在一起。当他在车边开始说那些胡话时，她以为这可能是他在向她搭讪的可爱方式。但现在她意识到这个眼神柔和、笑容羞涩的男人，真的是个疯子。他的手指紧紧扣着她的。他们就这样僵持了一分钟左右，他趴在地上，她弯着腰站在他上方，神情困惑。
"OK," Natasha whispered, in a gentle, almost therapeutic voice. "So, we're holding hands. Now what?"
“好了，”娜塔莎用温柔、近乎治疗般的语气低声说。“我们拉着手了。现在怎么办？”
"Now," Robbie said, "I'll turn the handle."
“现在，”罗比说，“我要转动手柄了。”
It took them a long time to find Igor. Igor was in pretty bad shape. His skin was yellow, and he was sweating heavily. But when he saw Natasha, his face lit up. He was so thrilled that he got up and hugged her, even though he could hardly stand. At that point, Natasha started to cry, and asked him to forgive her. Because this Igor wasn't just one of her lies, he was also her uncle, a made-up uncle, but still.
他们花了好长时间才找到伊戈尔。伊戈尔的情况很糟糕。他的皮肤发黄，大汗淋漓。但当他看到娜塔莎时，他的脸亮了起来。他太激动了，起身拥抱了她，尽管他几乎站不稳。那一刻，娜塔莎开始哭泣，请求他的原谅。因为这个伊戈尔不仅是她的谎言之一，也是她的叔叔，一个虚构的叔叔，但仍然是。
And Igor told her she shouldn't feel bad. The life she invented for him may not always have been easy, but he enjoyed every minute. And she had nothing to worry about because, compared to the car crash in Minsk, the stick-up in Odessa, the lightning that struck him in Vladivostok, and the pack of rabid wolves in Siberia, this heart attack was small change.
伊戈尔告诉她不必感到难过。她为他编造的人生或许并不总是容易的，但他享受每一分钟。她没什么可担心的，因为与明斯克的车祸、敖德萨的抢劫、海参崴的闪电袭击以及西伯利亚的一群狂狼相比，这次心脏病发作简直是小儿科。
And when they got back to the gumball machine, Robbie put in a one lira coin, took Natasha's hand and asked her to turn the handle. And when they were back in the yard, she found herself holding a plastic ball with a trinket inside, an ugly, silvery, heart-shaped charm.
当他们回到口香糖机前时，罗比投进一枚一里拉硬币，牵住娜塔莎的手，让她转动把手。当他们回到院子里时，她发现自己手里握着一个装着小饰品的塑料球，一个丑陋的、银色心形挂坠。
"You know," she said, "I was supposed to be going to Sinai tonight for a few days with a girlfriend, but I think I'm going to call it off and go back tomorrow to take care of Igor. Would you like to come?"
“你知道吗，”她说，“我本来今晚要和女朋友去西奈半岛玩几天，但我打算取消了，明天回去照顾伊戈尔。你想一起去吗？”
Robbie nodded. He knew he'd have to make something up at the office. He wasn't quite sure what it would be. All he knew was that it would be a happy lie, full of flowers and sunshine, maybe even a baby or two. And they'd be smiling.
罗比点点头。他知道他必须在办公室编造点什么。他还不确定会是什么。他只知道那会是一个快乐的谎言，充满鲜花和阳光，甚至可能还有一两个婴儿。他们会微笑着。
Actor Dermot Mulroney reading a story by Etgar Keret. The story was translated from the Hebrew by Miriam Schlesinger. Etgar has a new book of short stories called The Girl in the Fridge. His movie, Jellyfish , is in a handful of theaters around the country.
演员德蒙特·莫罗尼朗读埃特加·凯雷特的故事。该故事由米里亚姆·施莱辛格从希伯来语翻译而来。埃特加有一本新的短篇小说集叫《冰箱里的女孩》。他的电影《水母》正在全国少数几家影院上映。
Coming up, yes, when your parents get old, you have to help them run their lives, deal with doctors, handle emergencies, and of course, do their detective work. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，是的，当你的父母变老时，你必须帮助他们打理生活、应对医生、处理突发事件，当然，还有做他们的侦探。一分钟后揭晓。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week in our show we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "The truth will out," stories of people trying to get that rare thing to happen, for the truth to actually come out.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选定一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“真相必会大白”，关于人们试图让那种罕见的事情发生的故事，让真相真正被揭露出来。
We've arrived at act  two of our program. Act two-- "The spy who bugged me." Lawrence Wright got to the bottom of a mystery in his life by reading a front page article in the New York Times a couple of years ago. Wright is a reporter for the New Yorker Magazine .
我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕——“窃听我的间谍”。劳伦斯·赖特通过阅读几年前《纽约时报》头版的一篇文章，弄清了他生活中的一个谜团。赖特是《纽约客》杂志的记者。
And, most important, for the story you're about to hear, he's an expert on Al Qaeda. He won the Pulitzer prize for his book called, The Looming Tower: Al Qaeda and the Road to 9/11 , which reconstructed how we got to September 11. He's interviewed hundreds of people with links to jihadist organizations, including relatives of Osama bin Laden.
而且，最重要的是，对于你即将听到的这个故事，他是基地组织的专家。他因撰写《巨塔：基地组织与通往9/11之路》一书获得了普利策奖，该书重建了我们如何走向9月11日的过程。他采访过数百名与圣战组织有联系的人，包括奥萨马·本·拉登的亲属。
I got a call from one of those FBI agents that I had previously spoken with. And he said that he and another member of the Joint Terrorism Task Force in Austin wanted to come visit me. And I thought it was the same kind of thing, they were asking for guidance. But it was pretty clear that this was a more formal kind of interrogation.
我接到了以前采访过的一位联邦调查局特工的电话。他说他和奥斯汀联合反恐特遣队的另一名成员想来拜访我。我以为又是同样的事情，他们是在寻求指导。但很明显，这是一种更正式的盘问。
He and the other man, who was a member of the Food and Drug Administration, a clerk there, they were asking me questions about telephone calls that had been made from my home office number to a number in England. It was a plus 44207 number, and could I tell them who it is?
他和另一名男子，那个食品药品监督管理局（FDA）的一名职员，在问我关于从我的家庭办公室电话拨往英国的一个号码的通话。那是+44207开头的号码，问我能否告诉他们那是谁的？
And I said, well, you don't know? I mean, it seemed quite a failure of investigation that they couldn't figure out a London telephone number. But I said, I'll look on my computer. And so, I looked up on my Palm. And it belonged to Gareth Peirce, who is a solicitor that-- matter of fact, Emma Thompson played her in a movie called, In the Name of the Father. At that time, she had been representing IRA people, and now she was representing jihadis that I'd been talking to in London.
我说，你们不知道吗？这意味着他们连伦敦的电话号码都查不出来，调查能力实在太差。但我说，我可以在电脑上查一下。于是，我在我的掌上电脑上查了。那是加雷斯·皮尔斯（Gareth Peirce）的号码，她是一位律师——事实上，电影《因父之名》里就是艾玛·汤普森扮演的她。那时，她一直在为爱尔兰共和军（IRA）人员辩护，现在她正在为我在伦敦采访过的圣战分子辩护。
And so I told them who it was. And then they said, that we understand the person who initiated the calls is a person named Caroline. Somebody by that name in the house? I said, that's my daughter.
所以我告诉了他们那是谁。然后他们说，我们得知发起通话的人是个叫卡罗琳（Caroline）的人。家里有叫这个名字的人吗？我说，那是我女儿。
And they said, well, would her last name be Brown? I said no, but she just graduated from Brown. Caroline's name is not on any of our phones. So I don't know how her name would have arisen.
他们说，她的姓氏是布朗（Brown）吗？我说不，但她刚从布朗大学（Brown University）毕业。卡罗琳的名字不在我们的任何电话记录里。所以我不知道她的名字是怎么出现的。
What is your feeling as you're hearing this, is it fear, is it confusion? Describe your state of mind.
当你听到这些时，你的感觉是什么？是恐惧，是困惑？描述一下你的心态。
I would describe it as confusion boiling into anger, as I began to realize what must be going on. it suggested, they must have gotten information that they overheard. And I had assumed that the laws were such as they were written, that in order to listen to an American citizen's telephone conversations, one needs a warrant. It seemed really unlikely to me that there had been probable cause for a warrant for me.
我会把它描述为愤怒中酝酿着困惑，当我开始意识到发生了什么时。这暗示他们一定获得了监听到的信息。而我一直以为法律的规定是，要监听美国公民的电话谈话，需要搜查令。我觉得他们有理由对我签发搜查令的可能性极低。
And I didn't know at that time, nor did most Americans, that there was a secret program under way called the Terrorist Surveillance Program that superseded this. And it had been created by the White House, allowing warrantless wiretaps on an untold number of Americans.
当时我并不知道，大多数美国人也不知道，有一个名为“恐怖分子监视计划”的秘密计划正在运行，它凌驾于此之上。它是由白宫创建的，允许对无数美国人进行无证窃听。
So how'd you figure it out?
你是怎么发现的？
It was in December 2005, and I'd read the New York Times front page story about warrantless wiretaps. And I thought, that happened to me. It was just immediately a moment of recognition that that's what had gone on. At once, I connected the dots. The FBI coming to my house with what, obviously, seemed to be actual information that had come from my telephone call. All of that, suddenly fell into place.
那是2005年12月，我读了《纽约时报》关于无证窃听的头版文章。我心想，这发生在我身上了。那是瞬间的认识，意识到这就是发生过的事情。一下子，我把点连成线了。联邦调查局来到我家，带着明显似乎来自我电话通话的实际信息。所有这些，突然都对上了。
What had been puzzling me all along, was the law as it was written which forbid this kind of government intrusion. How did they know about these calls that I'd been making to London? And where did they get the name of my daughter? These things had been on the back of my mind for a couple of years. I couldn't figure out how, legally, those things could have happened. And then suddenly, I saw the New York Times story, and I realized that, well maybe it wasn't legal, but this is how they went about it.
一直困扰我的是法律明文禁止这种政府入侵。他们怎么知道我一直在拨打伦敦的电话？他们从哪儿弄到了我女儿的名字？这些事情在过去几年里一直在我脑海中盘旋。我搞不清楚这些事情在法律上是怎么发生的。然后突然间，我看到了《纽约时报》的报道，我意识到，好吧，也许这并不合法，但这正是他们采取的手段。
I see, right. And it's interesting, because, one of the things that people started to think about when that story first broke-- I know the question occurred to me, and I'm sure other people as well-- like, oh, does that mean that they've ever listened to me? The hard part about that story was there's no way to verify because you don't--
我明白了，对。这很有趣，因为当报道初次传出时，人们开始思考的一件事——我知道那个问题也曾出现在我脑海中，我相信其他人也是——比如，噢，这意味着他们曾经监听过我吗？那个故事难点在于没有办法证实，因为你……
They're not going to tell you.
他们不会告诉你的。
They're not going to tell you. So, it strikes me, that you're one of the few people in the country that actually knew they were being targeted by this program. And you ended up talking to the guy in charge of the program. You wrote a profile of Mike McConnell, he's the top dog in United States intelligence, for the New Yorker Magazine.
他们不会告诉你的。所以，我感到惊讶的是，你是全国少数几个确实知道自己被该计划作为目标的人之一。你最终和该计划的负责人进行了交谈。你为《纽约客》杂志撰写了迈克·麦康奈尔（Mike McConnell）的简介，他是美国情报界的最高长官。
That's correct.
没错。
So again, you're in a completely unique position. You're one of the few people who actually knows that you were targeted by this wireless surveillance program. And now, you're writing a profile of the person who's in charge of that program. When did you first to bring up your own experience with this program, with him?
所以再一次，你处于一个完全独特的位置。你是少数几个确实知道自己被该无线监视计划作为目标的人之一。而现在，你在撰写该计划负责人的简介。你什么时候第一次向他提起你自己的经历？
The first we had a conversation was in early July last year. And it was a, kind of, get acquainted meeting. And he was talking about the thing that was most on his mind, was for him to have more flexibility in accessing calls between people abroad and American citizens or people who might be in America at that time.
我们第一次对话是在去年7月初。那是一个熟人性质的会议。他谈论的是他最关心的事情，就是为了让他在获取海外人员与美国公民或当时可能在美国的人员之间的通话时有更多的灵活性。
And I said, in the interest of full disclosure, I want you to know that I've been monitored. He seemed a little surprised and taken aback. And I told him about the FBI coming to my house. And we went over this conversation three or four different times in the course of our interviews, because he kept coming back to it. It clearly got under his skin.
我说，出于全面披露的利益，我想让你知道我曾受到监视。他似乎有点吃惊和措手不及。我告诉了他联邦调查局来到我家的事。我们在采访过程中把这个谈话复盘了三四次，因为他不断回到这个话题。这显然触动了他的神经。
Because I told him about them getting Caroline's name. It really bugs me, because I don't know how her name could have come up. And so he said, well maybe you mentioned her name. Which is what I think that probably happened, but that obviously implies they are listening to it.
因为我告诉了他他们获得了卡罗琳名字的事。这真的很让我困扰，因为我不知道她的名字怎么会出现。所以他说，也许你提到了她的名字。这正是我认为可能发生的事情，但这显然意味着他们在监听。
And I said, well that troubles me. And his response was, it may be troublesome, it may not be. You don't know. And of course, that's exactly the position any American citizen would be in.
我说，这让我感到不安。他的回答是，这可能令人不安，也可能不会。你不知道。当然，这正是任何美国公民会处在的位置。
Did you ask him, is that something that should be happening? Should your daughter's name-- should that become information that is now in the hands of the intelligence community?
你问过他，这是应该发生的事情吗？你女儿的名字——这应该成为现在掌握在情报界手中的信息吗？
You know, he didn't seem to be particularly disturbed that my daughter's name would have arisen in it. His response, essentially, is that I have to trust the government. But first of all, there were profound misunderstandings involved in our case, in my daughter and myself. And secondly, we have a history of a government that exceeds its authority and has often intruded on to people's lives such as-- even McConnell and I talked about it.
你知道，他似乎并不特别困扰我女儿的名字会出现在里面。他的回答本质上是我必须信任政府。但首先，我们的案件中涉及深刻的误解，涉及我女儿和我自己。其次，我们有一段政府超越其权力、经常侵入人们生活的历史，就像——甚至我和麦康奈尔都谈论过。
When he was young, growing up in South Carolina, there were these big billboards on the side of the highway, impeach Earl Warren, who was Chief Justice of the Supreme Court. And then, it made quite an impression on him, when he got into the intelligence business to learn that the intelligence community, the FBI had actually been wiretapping the Supreme Court Justice's own telephone and other members of the supreme court and of course, Martin Luther King and civil rights activists.
当他年轻时，在南卡罗来纳州长大，高速公路边有巨大的广告牌，写着“弹劾厄尔·沃伦”（Earl Warren），他曾是最高法院首席大法官。当他进入情报界了解到情报界和联邦调查局实际上一直在窃听最高法院大法官本人的电话以及最高法院的其他成员，当然还有马丁·路德·金和民权活动家时，这让他留下了深刻的印象。
The history of our government's overreaching into the private lives of American citizens is really profound. It's one thing to give the power to the government to try to prevent terrorists from attacking America. I understand the thinking about that, but when you actually see it at work, you realize how flawed and human the operators are behind it. And what kinds of mistakes that they can make. They could be potentially very damaging to people's lives.
我们政府在私人公民私生活方面的越权历史真的是深不可测。赋予政府权力以防止恐怖分子袭击美国是一回事。我理解这种思维，但当你真正看到它在运作时，你会意识到背后的操作者是多么有缺陷和人性。他们可能会犯什么样的错误。他们可能对人们的生活造成极其严重的损害。
I do remember when the FBI and the FDA clerk came to my office, I had a big whiteboard with names of Al Qaeda members written all over it. My book was all laid out. I had thousands and thousands of note cards with bin Laden and Zawahiri and all the members of Al Qaeda, and dozens and dozens of books and so on. Either I was an avid reporter or I was an insider in Al Qaeda. From the look on the face of the FDA clerk, it was probably the latter. He had a bead of sweat on his upper lip. He thought he must have stumbled into some den.
我确实记得当联邦调查局特工和FDA职员来到我的办公室时，我有一块巨大的白板，上面写满了基地组织成员的名字。我的书全都铺开了。我有成千上万张卡片，上面有本·拉登、扎瓦希里和所有基地组织成员的名字，还有几十本几十本的书等等。要么我是一个狂热的记者，要么我是基地组织的内部成员。从那个FDA职员脸上的表情看，很可能是后者。他上唇冒着汗珠。他觉得他一定是误闯进了什么巢穴。
Is your response to try to let him sweat or is your response to try  to reassure him as much as possible?
你的回应是试图让他流汗，还是你的回应是试图尽可能让他安心？
I thought it was the kind of absurd. Because it's one of those moments when you begin to see how it might look in another person's eyes. He worked for the Food and Drug Administration. This is not his main gig. So, suddenly he comes out, and he comes into this room, and it's just filled with Al Qaeda memorabilia and information, and so on. And I can see through his eyes, suddenly, that he must feel like, this could really be real. I was a little amused by the look in his face, but I also realized it was kind of dangerous. That level of misinterpretation could get me in trouble.
我觉得那很荒谬。因为那是你开始看到它在别人眼中可能是什么样子的时刻之一。他为食品药品监督管理局工作。这不是他的主要工作。所以，突然他走了出来，进入这个房间，里面全是基地组织的纪念品和信息等等。透过他的眼睛，我突然能看出，他一定觉得这可能是真的。他的表情让我觉得有点好笑，但我也意识到这有点危险。那种误解程度可能会让我陷入麻烦。
Have you changed your behavior at all now that you know that your phone calls were listened to, and that the government was acting outside the law as you understood it? Has it made you change your behavior, in terms of like, what you say on the phone, how you talk to people, what you leave around the house?
既然你知道你的电话被监听，而且政府正如你所理解的那样行事逾越了法律，你现在的行为有没有任何改变？它有没有让你改变自己的行为，比如你在电话里说了什么，你怎么和人交谈，你在家里留了什么东西？
Alex, I've been talking to other reporters about this. You know, there's a dilemma. I was talking to some Times reporters-- they've been advised by one of their intelligence sources that they should get new cell phones. ABC had a similar kind of discussion about whether we should all change our phones, or whether we should behave like terrorists by getting disposable cell phones, have a conversation and throw it away. That's the way terrorists evade this kind of monitoring.
亚历克斯，我一直在和其他记者谈论这件事。你知道，这是一个两难境地。我正在和一些《时报》记者交谈——他们被一位情报线人建议应该换新手机。美国广播公司也有过类似的讨论，关于我们是否都应该换电话，或者我们是否应该像恐怖分子那样通过购买一次性手机，通话后就扔掉。那是恐怖分子规避这种监控的方式。
I, so far, haven't done that. And maybe I'm being naive about it, but there are times when, if I come up on a question that might require a really confidential answer, that I've been more interested in doing it in person than on the phone.
我到目前为止还没这样做。也许我很天真，但有时，如果我遇到一个可能需要极其机密答案的问题，我会更倾向于面对面沟通，而不是在电话里讲。
Have you had a situation where you realize that you know more about Al Qaeda than the people who are supposed to be the experts?
你有没有遇到过这种情况，意识到你知道的关于基地组织的情况比那些所谓的专家还要多？
All the time. I mean, it's pretty demoralizing when you are talking to people that are on the Al Qaeda Squad, and they can't pronounce the names of these guys. When the head of counterterrorism for the FBI testifies under oath that he doesn't know the difference between a Sunni and a Shiite. and he thinks that's an irrelevant question. I mean, if you don't know the first thing about the enemy you're fighting, you're always going to be handicapped, blindfolded, deaf-and-dumb. And really, that's the situation that you find.
经常。我是说，当你和那些在“基地组织小组”的人交谈，而他们甚至无法正确发音这些家伙的名字时，真的很令人沮丧。当联邦调查局的反恐主管在宣誓作证时说他不知道逊尼派和什叶派的区别，并且认为这是一个不相关的问题。我是说，如果你对你正在打击的敌人连第一点都不了解，你永远会处于劣势，被蒙住眼睛，又聋又哑。而这确实就是你所发现的情况。
It seems like, in a weird way, that is the most frustrating thing of this whole thing. If it seemed like they had more information than you do, with their heightened ability, than it would maybe make more sense. But it seems like they're doing all this, and it's still not putting them ahead of a single reporter with no special access to anybody and just his own reporting skills. I mean, is that too strong?
似乎，以一种奇怪的方式，这是整件事中最令人沮丧的地方。如果他们看起来比你拥有更多的信息，凭借他们更强的能力，那可能更有道理。但看起来他们做了所有这一切，却仍然没有领先于一名没有任何特殊渠道、只有自己报道技巧的记者。我是说，这样说会不会太强硬？
No, it's not at all. There are some good people involved in this effort. I'm not denigrating them. But when I wrote my book, one of the heroes in my book was a native Arabic speaking FBI agent who came closer than anybody to stopping 9/11. He was one of eight Arabic speaking agents in the FBI at that time. Now, nearly seven years later, there are nine.
不，一点也不。在这项努力中确实有一些好人。我不是在诋毁他们。但当我写我的书时，书中的英雄之一是一名以阿拉伯语为母语的联邦调查局特工，他比任何人都更接近于阻止9/11。他是当时联邦调查局八名能说阿拉伯语的特工之一。现在，近七年后，有九名。
And I'm picking on the FBI because they are open about their figures. It's true all across the intelligence community. They don't have the kind of people that really understand who these people are, where they come from, and what they're fighting for. Who's in the FBI, especially in headquarters seventh floor in Washington? Irish and Italian guys.
我挑联邦调查局的毛病，是因为他们对数据持开放态度。整个情报界也是如此。他们没有那种真正理解这些人是谁、他们来自哪里、他们在为什么而战的人。谁在联邦调查局，特别是在华盛顿总部七楼？爱尔兰裔和意大利裔小伙子。
And if you look at the history of that organization, which made its reputation fighting the mafia and, to some extent, the IRA, it's no wonder that they were successful in fighting against those communities. They came from the same neighborhoods. They spoke the same languages. They knew the culture. They don't know these people.
如果你看看那个组织的成长史，它的名声是在打击黑手党和某种程度上打击爱尔兰共和军的过程中建立起来的，难怪他们在打击这些群体时很成功。他们来自同一个社区。他们说同样的语言。他们了解文化。他们不了解这些人。
And if you have family in the Middle East, essentially, you are not going to be a candidate to be in America's intelligence community. And that rules out almost everybody who fluently, natively speaks not just Arabic, but Farsi, Dari, Pashto, all these languages of these communities that we need to understand so vitally. We've done such a poor job of understanding, much less penetrating and disrupting that organization simply because we don't have the right people.
如果你在中东有家人，从本质上讲，你就不可能成为美国情报界的候选人。这排除掉了几乎所有不仅仅是阿拉伯语，还有波斯语、达里语、普什图语等我们迫切需要理解的这些社区语言的流利母语使用者。我们做得很烂，没能去理解，更不用说渗透和瓦解那个组织了，仅仅因为我们没有合适的人。
Lawrence Wright, talking to This American Life producer Alex Blumberg. Wright is the author of the book The Looming Tower . Just a few weeks ago, he did another story about Al Qaeda for The New Yorker. You can read that story for free on the magazine's website, newyorker.com where you can find lots of great stories.
劳伦斯·赖特，与《美国生活》制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格交谈。赖特是《巨塔》一书的作者。就在几周前，他为《纽约客》写了另一篇关于基地组织的故事。你可以在该杂志的网站newyorker.com上免费阅读那篇文章，在那里你可以找到许多精彩的故事。
Act three-- "Rosa in the Study with the ATM Card." We close today's show about uncovering the truth with a story about how difficult it can be to get to what really happened, even when you're looking at what seems like the simplest kind of crime possible. To preserve everybody's privacy in this story, we have changed all their names. And the woman in the story, who is going to remain anonymous, has an elderly dad. He's over 80, and he's has gone through a variety of medical emergencies, kidney stones, growth on scalp, heart attack, blood in his urine, hernia surgery. And he has several caretakers who come to his house. His daughter steps when there's a crisis.
第三幕——“书房里的罗莎与自动取款机卡”。我们今天关于揭开真相的节目将以一个故事结尾，这个故事关于即便你在观察看似最简单的犯罪类型时，想要弄清究竟发生了什么有多么困难。为了保护本故事中每个人的隐私，我们更改了他们所有的名字。故事中的这位女士，她将保持匿名，有一位年迈的父亲。他80多岁了，经历过各种医疗紧急情况，肾结石、头皮增生、心脏病发作、尿血、疝气手术。他有几位护理人员来他家。当有危机时，女儿会介入。
During a recent visit, my father tells me that Lourdes, who cooks his meals, is on the verge of quitting. "It is something about Rosa," my father says.
在最近的一次拜访中，我父亲告诉我，负责他餐食的卢尔德（Lourdes）快要辞职了。“和罗莎（Rosa）有关，”我父亲说。
I look at him blankly. "Rosa?"
我茫然地看着他。“罗莎？”
"You found her for me," he says.
“是你给我找的，”他说。
"You mean they sent her from one of the agencies," I remind him.
“你是说他们从代理机构派她来的，”我提醒他。
"I guess so. Anyway, can you deal with it?"
“我想是吧。不管怎样，你能处理一下吗？”
As my father has aged, he's grown proficient at delegating. Some of this stems from his Parkinson's, but some of it is just my dad. Though he grew up working-class in the depression, his passions run more in the line of those of a rich, country squire: opera, fine wine, domestic servants. Gradually, he's enlisted a growing army of caretakers to minister to his needs.
随着父亲年迈，他变得很擅长授权。这部分源于他的帕金森病，但部分只是我爸的原因。尽管他在大萧条时期作为工人阶级长大，但他的热情更接近于富有的乡绅：歌剧、名酒、家仆。渐渐地，他招募了一支日益壮大的护理大军来服侍他的需求。
Lourdes arrives at his house later that afternoon. I ask her if there is anything she wants to say.
卢尔德当天下午晚些时候到达他家。我问她有什么想说的。
"Si," she says pivoting towards my father. "I'm leaving you, Mr. Ken. There are too many people in your business. Yesterday, you couldn't find your cash. And I don't know who this Rosa is. Why does she have your ATM? I ask you two times Mr. Ken, who is this Rosa?"
“是的，”她转向我父亲说。“我要辞职了，肯先生。干预你私事的人太多了。昨天，你找不到你的现金了。我不认识这个罗莎是谁。为什么她有你的自动取款机卡？肯先生，我问了你两次，这个罗莎是谁？”
"It sounds like you don't trust her," I say to Lourdes.
“听起来你不信任她，”我对卢尔德说。
"No, she is always whispering, giggling, an ass kisser."
“不，她总是窃窃私语、咯咯笑，是个马屁精。”
A couple weeks later, I get a message from my dad's bookkeeper, Amy, the general of my father's army of caretakers. "I'm looking at your dad's books and there's something going on here," she says ominously. "Please, give me a call as soon as it's convenient."
几周后，我收到了父亲会计艾米（Amy）的信息，她是父亲护理大军的统帅。“我在看你父亲的账目，这儿有点情况，”她语带威胁地说。“方便的话请尽快给我回电。”
Amy tells me she's discovered strange charges on my dad's Visa card, huge ATM withdrawals, and fat checks signed in an unfamiliar handwriting and made out to a woman named Rosa. "I'm looking at upwards of $6,000 missing from your dad's checking accounts. And then there's $20,000 that seems to be missing from his investments," she says. "I never heard of this Rosa before. Your dad says you found her."
艾米告诉我她发现我父亲的Visa卡上有奇怪的收费，巨额的自动取款机提现，以及签着陌生笔迹、支付给一位叫罗莎的女人的大额支票。“我看到你父亲的支票账户少了6000多美元。然后还有20000美元似乎从他的投资里不见了，”她说。“我以前从没听说过这个罗莎。你父亲说是你找她的。”
For the rest of the day, my brother and I are on the phone with Amy getting updates on her accounting discoveries. For a long time, we kids have felt my father is pressing his luck living alone. Amy calls to say she has gone over to my father's and confronted him.
那天剩下的时间里，我和哥哥一直与艾米通电话，获取她会计发现的更新。长期以来，我们做子女的一直觉得父亲独自生活是在碰运气。艾米打电话来说她已经去过父亲那儿，当面质问了他。
Apparently, he told her it was all easily explained. He had lent Rosa money for her mortgage. Amy says, she asked to see the paperwork for the loan, and he refused. Then he said it was a gift. Then he said he didn't remember.
显然，他告诉她这一切都很容易解释。他借钱给罗莎交房贷了。艾米说，她要求看贷款的文件，但他拒绝了。然后他说那是赠礼。然后他说他不记得了。
Amy goes on, "I found these weird charges, like one at Macy's and another Victoria's Secret," she says. "Your father says, he was out with Rosa, and she saw some jewelry, and so he bought it for her. He said it was only $40. And I said, but Ken, the charge was for almost $100. And he said, oh well, maybe that was it." Then she adds, "Lourdes told me she thinks Rosa is a prostitute, because of how she acts and dresses. She says she thinks your father has fallen in love with her."
艾米继续说，“我发现了一些奇怪的收费，比如一笔在梅西百货（Macy's），另一笔在维多利亚的秘密（Victoria's Secret），”她说。“你父亲说，他和罗莎一起外出，她看中了一些珠宝，所以他给她买了。他说只有40美元。我说，但肯，那一笔收费快100美元了。他说，噢，好吧，也许就是那笔。”然后她补充说，“卢尔德告诉我，她认为罗莎是个妓女，因为她的言行举止。她说她认为你父亲爱上她了。”
Apparently, Lourdes has told Amy that she's been cleaning up a lot of dinners for two with wine glasses, which she took to be signs that Rosa was visiting him at night. I get this awful feeling. Amy tells me she has a plan.
显然，卢尔德告诉艾米，她一直在清理很多喝过两杯葡萄酒的晚餐餐具，她认为那是罗莎晚上来访的迹象。我有一种可怕的感觉。艾米告诉我她有个计划。
She wants to go to my father's house tomorrow morning when Rosa is scheduled to pick up my father for a dentist appointment. The plan is to confront Rosa and get to the bottom of this. Amy's husband, who happens to be a high-ranking military officer just home from Iraq, will also help. She wants me to be there too.
她想在明天早上罗莎预定去接我父亲看牙医时去他家。计划是当面质问罗莎，把这件事查个水落石出。艾米的丈夫，刚好是刚从伊拉克回国的高级军事官员，也会帮忙。她想让我也在场。
The next morning, I drive south through the oaky hills of central California to my father's home. As I approach, the weedy medians give way to manicured landscaping, roses, carved bushes, and lawns clipped like French velvet. My father had once cultivated a similarly refined community of friends, people with multiple homes, colleagues with charitable trusts, but now that's changed.
第二天早上，我驱车南下，穿过加利福尼亚州中部橡树覆盖的丘陵，前往父亲的家。当我靠近时，杂草丛生的中央隔离带让位于修剪整齐的园林，玫瑰、修剪过的灌木，草坪像法国天鹅绒一样整齐。我父亲曾经营过一个同样精致的社交圈，有多个房产的人、有慈善信托的同事，但现在变了。
Though he still lives in the same place, his friends mostly include his caretakers and their families. A lot of them live paycheck to paycheck. He hear stories about broken hearts and broken down cars, bouts of depression and unemployment, and tells them to me.
尽管他依然住在同一个地方，但他的朋友大多包括他的护理人员及其家人。他们许多人过着月光族的生活。他听到关于破碎的心、抛锚的车、抑郁和失业的故事，然后把这些讲给我听。
When I arrive, my father sits in the monstrous Naugahyde recliner we bought for him, a veritable throne of old age. C-SPAN is on, as it often is.
当我到达时，父亲坐在我们为他买的硕大的人造革躺椅上，那真是一张老年的宝座。C-SPAN（电视网）正开着，正如往常一样。
"I'm glad you came," my father says.
“很高兴你来了，”父亲说。
When Amy and her husband, Mike, pull up, I meet them outside. Mike is wearing crisply ironed fatigues and army boots. We enter the house, and Amy bends down to my father and hugs him. She broaches the subject of Rosa's use of his Visa over the weekend, which my father gave her to buy herself some hospital scrubs for a new job.
当艾米和她丈夫迈克（Mike）车停下时，我在外面见到了他们。迈克穿着熨烫得笔挺的军装和军靴。我们走进屋子，艾米弯腰拥抱了我父亲。她提到了罗莎周末使用他的Visa卡的事，父亲给她卡是让她给自己买护士工作服。
"We're looking at nearly $700 spent at Target and Walmart," Amy says. "If it turns out she's stolen this money, do you agree to press charges?"
“我们看到在Target和沃尔玛花费了近700美元，”艾米说。“如果事实证明她偷了这笔钱，你同意提起诉讼吗？”
My father looks at her, "You haven't met her. You can't just accuse someone. You don't even know her."
我父亲看着她，“你还没见过她。你不能就这样指责别人。你甚至不了解她。”
"Ken, I don't need to know her. I have the evidence right here. What kind of services is she providing to you, Ken?" she asks.
“肯，我不需要了解她。证据就在这儿。她在为你提供什么样的服务，肯？”她问。
"Nothing."
“没什么。”
Her face is inches from his. "I know this is hard for you  to accept that someone you care for is taking advantage of you, but what's going on is just not right."
她的脸距离他只有几英寸。“我知道让你接受一个你关心的人正在利用你是件很难的事，但目前发生的事情是不对的。”
"You shouldn't accuse her. You need to talk to her first." My father bangs his hand on the arm of the chair, "God damn it. I've told you everything is all right, and it is. If you won't listen to me, you can get out of my house." His hands are shaking, but not the loose trembling that comes from neurological misfiring. It's concentrated rage.
“你不应该指责她。你需要先和她谈谈。”我父亲拍着扶手吼道，“去他妈的。我告诉过你一切都好，而且确实很好。如果你不听我的，你可以离开我的家。”他的手在颤抖，但不是那种神经放电带来的松散震颤。这是一种集中的愤怒。
Amy stands, "You want me to leave? I'm leaving." Mike stands, holding Amy's coat for her. Amy turns to dad, "It won't break my business, losing you as a client, but it will break my heart."
艾米站起身，“你要我走？我走。”迈克站起来，为艾米拿着外套。艾米转向我父亲，“失去你这个客户不会搞垮我的生意，但这会伤了我的心。”
As she walks towards the door, I look at my father, "Dad, say something."
当她走向门口时，我看着父亲，“爸，说点什么。”
My dad relents, "I don't really want you to go," he says. "I just don't want you yelling at this woman."
我爸妥协了，“我其实并不想让你走，”他说。“我只是不想让你对着这个女人大吼大叫。”
We sit and wait. Finally, an old-model American car pulls up. We peer through the windows, careful not to tip her off. Then Rosa walks in. She's wearing baggy layers over a heavyset frame. Her hair is cut short. She wears no makeup. She bears no resemblance to the Victoria Secret-wearing wine-swilling seductress I had imagined.
我们坐着等待。终于，一辆旧型号的美国车停下了。我们透过窗户观察，小心不让她察觉。然后罗莎走了进来。她穿着肥大的层叠衣服，身材厚实。头发剪得很短。没化什么妆。她和我想象中那个穿着维多利亚的秘密、贪杯的诱惑者形象一点都不像。
She walks into the room and kisses my father on the cheek. "How are you, Ken?" she asks.
她走进房间，吻了父亲的脸颊。“你好吗，肯？”她问。
"I've been better," says my dad.
“我以前更好过，”我爸说。
Then she looks around, noticing the strange faces in the room. Amy, Mike and I introduce ourselves and shake hands with her. Mike stand sentry at the door. Amy asks her to sit down and tells her that there's money missing from Ken's accounts. We ask her about getting a loan or a gift from Ken.
然后她环顾四周，注意到了房间里的陌生面孔。艾米、迈克和我做了自我介绍，并和她握了手。迈克在门口充当哨兵。艾米让她坐下，告诉她肯的账户里缺了钱。我们问她关于从肯那儿借贷款或接受赠礼的事。
She looks baffled and turns to my father, "No, Ken, I earned that money. Remember, I spent 10 days here, 12 hour shifts." My father nods.
她显得很困惑，转向我父亲，“不，肯，那是我的酬劳。记得吗，我在这里待了10天，轮班12小时。”我父亲点点头。
I explain, "It's that he can't exactly recall how this money has been spent, but he's spending it a lot faster than he has in the past."
我解释说，“他记不清钱是怎么花的，但他花钱比过去快多了。”
She looks at me pleadingly, "I'm sorry," she says quietly. "I thought he was alert."
她恳求地看着我，“对不起，”她轻声说。“我以为他头脑清醒。”
Point by point, Amy goes over his suspicious expenditures. At every point, Rosa defends herself. All the hours she's been working, neither she nor Ken kept track, but she says they were extensive. The Visa use over the weekend, she bought a lot of scrubs and planned to pay my father back.
逐条地，艾米列举了他可疑的开支。在每一项上，罗莎都在为自己辩护。她工作的所有时间，她和肯都没记录，但她说那是大量的。周末使用Visa卡，她买了很多工作服，并计划还给父亲。
Since my father gives out his ATM card to all his caretakers, she can't really be expected to explain all the withdrawals. She says the checks made out to her name were payment for more work. I don't know what to think. The relationship between my father and his caretakers is so intimate. They do stuff for him I won't do, all for a few bucks an hour.
既然父亲把他的自动取款机卡给了所有的护理人员，确实不能指望她解释所有的提现。她说以她名义开的支票是更多工作的酬劳。我不知道该怎么想。我父亲和他的护理人员之间的关系太亲密了。他们为他做我不愿意做的事，每小时却只赚几块钱。
It hardly seems crazy that my father and Rosa might have had long talks over dinner, that my father would have wanted to repay her kindness, and that Rosa would have wanted to accept. Still, I can tell Amy remains unmoved. For her, the numbers tell the whole story. If I defend Rosa, dad will lose both Lourdes and Amy, and I still won't know what happened.
我父亲和罗莎吃晚餐时聊很久，父亲想报答她的善意，罗莎想接受这份好意，这似乎一点都不疯狂。不过，我看得出艾米依然不为所动。对她来说，数字说明了一切。如果我捍卫罗莎，父亲会失去卢尔德和艾米，而我仍然不知道发生了什么。
With halfhearted logic, I decide she's crossed some professional line Even if she isn't swindling my dad, caretakers shouldn't go shopping for jewelry with their clients or use the client's ATM card to buy hundreds of dollars' worth of clothing. When I tell Rosa she can't work for Ken anymore, she looks like she doesn't know what hit her.
带着半信半疑的逻辑，我觉得她越界了。即使她没骗我爸，护理人员也不应该带着客户去买珠宝，或者用客户的自动取款机卡买几百美元的衣服。当我告诉罗莎她不能再为肯工作时，她看起来完全懵了。
"Can I say goodbye to him?" she asks.
“我可以和他道别吗？”她问。
I watched her lean over him and whisper in his ear. I realize, if this were a movie, and I were watching this scene, I know one thing for sure. I'd hate the daughter. After it happened, we really didn't talk about it. I wondered if he was angry at us, or if he just wanted to forget the whole incident. He's 81 and tires easily. But I thought that if I could just get him to tell me what he thought happened, I could stop guessing.
我看着她俯身在他耳边低语。我意识到，如果这是一部电影，而我正在看这一幕，我肯定知道一件事。我会恨死那个女儿。事情发生后，我们并没有真正讨论过。我想知道他是在生我们的气，还是只是想忘记整个事件。他81岁了，容易疲劳。但我认为，如果我能让他告诉我他认为发生了什么，我就不用猜了。
Well, what do you remember? I mean, do you remember giving her a loan, or do you remember giving her gifts?
那么，你记得什么？我是说，你记得借给她一笔贷款，还是记得给她赠礼？
Yes, I gave her $1,000 because she had a $3,000 mortgage. She was divorced. She didn't have a lot of money. She was in transition from one job to another. And I helped her out.
是的，我给了她1000美元，因为她有3000美元的房贷。她离婚了。她没多少钱。她正处于从一份工作过渡到另一份工作的阶段。我帮了她一把。
And did you feel like, did you think at some point that it was a loan or a gift?
你当时觉得，你是否在某个时刻认为那是贷款还是赠礼？
I guess originally, I thought of it as a loan, but I think as time went on, I assumed it would be a gift because she just couldn't pay it back in any reasonable time. And that was fine with me. It still was helpful to her, and I felt good about it.
我想最初我是把它当作贷款的，但随着时间推移，我认为那会是赠礼，因为她在任何合理的时间内都还不上。这对我来说没问题。这对她仍然有帮助，我感觉很好。
So, how did you feel when people started to question your judgment?
那么，当人们开始质疑你的判断力时，你有什么感觉？
Well, I didn't like it of course, because I felt like it was my own business, what I did with my money. You know, you might be heir to my money, but you don't control it now, right?
嗯，我当然不喜欢，因为我觉得我怎么花自己的钱是我自己的事。你知道，你可能是我的遗产继承人，但你现在没权力控制它，对吧？
Right.
对。
I feel like I've been misrepresented on the situation, that I can't take care of myself. And that I somewhat resented it, because I felt like I was in control. You know, I know these things happen, where these older people get taken. I just didn't feel like I was one of them. Even if she had taken me for every dime, it wouldn't be a big deal. It's not a lot of money.
我觉得我在那次情况中被误解了，认为我照顾不好自己。我有点反感，因为我觉得我在掌控中。你知道，我知道这种情况会发生，那些老年人被欺骗。我只是不觉得自己是其中之一。即使她骗走了我每一分钱，那也没什么大不了的。那也不是很多钱。
It also made me feel like, you're were kind of feeling a certain kind of sympathy. Where you were like, even if she stole several thousand bucks from me, that's not a big deal. She's struggling, she's got little kids.
这也让我觉得，你当时确实有一种同情心。你当时觉得，即使她偷了我几千块钱，那也不是什么大事。她生活艰难，还有小孩。
Right, absolutely. Absolutely, that's part of it. From what I understand, she's a good mother. She just struggles to get along. Anyway, I'm tired of talking about it.
对，绝对。绝对，那是其中一部分。据我了解，她是个好母亲。她只是努力度日。不管怎样，我不想再谈这个了。
OK.
好的。
My father never used to seem like someone who lost sleep over other people's troubles, especially people radically different from him. But now I think he might. Amy the bookkeeper tells me, she's always canceling generous contributions he makes to far flung charities he's seen on late night TV. She thinks these bouts of insomniac philanthropy are a sign he's not looking out for his own best interests.
我父亲过去似乎不是那种会为别人的麻烦而失眠的人，尤其是那些与他大相径庭的人。但现在我想他可能是了。会计艾米告诉我，她一直在取消他向半夜电视上看到的偏远慈善机构捐出的慷慨善款。她认为这些失眠的慈善行为是他没有为自己的最佳利益着想的信号。
But I'm not so sure. What if instead, my father is becoming the person we all want to be, someone who doesn't fixate on the bottom line, but empathizes with people in need. Then again, as I'm getting ready to go home after our interview, I hear my dad talking on the phone, making an appointment, giving out his address. When I inquire who it was, he says it was a very nice guy selling reverse mortgages. "A telemarketer," I ask, "coming to your home?"
但我不太确定。如果相反，我父亲正在成为我们都想成为的那种人呢？一个不专注于利润底线，而是对有需要的人感同身受的人。话又说回来，当我采访结束后准备回家时，听到我爸在电话里和人约时间，给出他的地址。当我问是谁时，他说是一个推销反向抵押贷款的好人。“电话推销员，”我问，“要上门？”
"Don't worry," he says, playing with the remote control. "I know what I'm doing."
“别担心，”他说，玩弄着遥控器。“我知道我在干什么。”
Well our show was produced today by our senior producer, Julie Snyder and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Lisa Shipley, and Nancy Updike. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help Seth Lind, Odette Yousef. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Special thanks to Bob Carlson and Sarah Vowell. Our website-- www.ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
今天的节目是由高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和我本人，以及亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞门（Robyn Semien）、莉萨·希普利（Lisa Shipley）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）共同制作的。阿德里安·马西欧维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）管理我们的网站。制作助理塞思·林德（Seth Lind）、奥黛特·优素福（Odette Yousef）。音乐协助杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。特别感谢鲍勃·卡尔森（Bob Carlson）和莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。我们的网站——www.ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management are excited for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who knocked on my door at 5:00 in the morning today, unshaved and disheveled, looking like hell. He explained it this way, "My dead mother appeared in my dream and asked me to buy her gumball. So I came here to look for change."
WBEZ管理层对我们的节目非常兴奋，由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他今天早上5点敲了我的门，没刮胡子，衣衫不整，看起来糟透了。他这样解释，“死去的母亲出现在我的梦里，让我给她买口香糖。所以我来这儿找零钱。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life. PRI Public Radio International.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》，带来更多故事。PRI，国际公共广播电台。